[MUSIC PLAYING]
VISHNU SIVAJI: Good afternoon.
I'm Vishnu Sivaji.
I'm a product
manager on G Suite,
and I'm joined
here by Allen Yang.
We actually are product
managers on Google Docs.
So if you have any
specific feature requests,
feel free to grab
us right after.
We'll try to help you out.
In the next hour, we're
going to demonstrate
ways in which G Suite apps,
like Google Docs, empower you
and your legal teams when you're
working with legal scenarios.
But before we get
started, I want
to know more about who exactly
we're talking to today.
So I'd like to know
how many lawyers we
have in the audience.
OK.
How about people
who are not lawyers,
but work with legal documents?
OK, more people.
All right, how many people
work with legal documents,
are not lawyers, but
pretend to be lawyers?
Oh, there's one
person, all right.
So we're going to start
by playing a short clip.
In this video, you're going to
see special types of lawyers
collaborate on a special
type of legal document,
and they're actually
going to be Google
Doc-- are going to be using
Google Docs for this process.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- One of the most exciting
things about Constitute
is its relationship
with Google Docs.
Today at the National
Constitution Center,
we've convened a
really unique group
of constitutional
drafters and others
who have expertise in
constitutional design.
- I'm a lawyer from Kenya.
- And I'm from Ukraine.
We are a currently
supporting the activities
of the constitution commission.
- I'm currently the
chief technical adviser
for the Liberian Constitute
[INAUDIBLE] process.
- And we've asked
these participants
to imagine an amendment on
the topic of campaign finance.
They'll use concept to
identify what excerpts
they find most interesting.
They'll then export
those excerpts directly
into Google Docs.
From there, they'll
collaborate on that Google Doc.
They'll mark up those
documents, comment, edit,
discuss those documents
in the margin.
- And so constitutions
are supposed
to be a popular exercise.
They're supposed to be
collaborative in their nature
in the way that they're made.
- So all those in favor
of [INAUDIBLE] amendment
as written, raise your hand.
OK, so it passes.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK END]
VISHNU SIVAJI: So we're going
to come back to this at the end,
because I want to show
you an example where
an actual country redrafted
their entire constitution using
Google Docs.
Now you're probably not drafting
constitutions on a daily basis.
You're working, though,
with legal documents
that do have a pretty big
impact on your company's future.
Today, we're going to talk
about three main things.
First, we're going to
highlight the powerful features
in Google Docs that help you
efficiently draft and polish
legal documents, whether
or not you're working
by yourself or with a team.
Next, Alan is going to talk
about external collaboration,
and that means
collaborating with people
outside your company
or perhaps negotiating.
And we're going to show you
how G Suite works great,
even if these partners
may not be on G Suite.
And lastly, we
want you to do all
of this in a secure,
confidential, and compliant
environment.
So we have a few
special speakers
from G Suite who are going
to cover adoption, security,
and compliance.
How many of you have
use Google Docs?
OK, Google Docs to do
work, like not in school.
OK, Google Docs to
do work and actually
drafting legal documents.
OK.
So the numbers got smaller.
That's fine.
I want to show you
that Docs is not just
great for your day-to-day
documents like meeting notes,
but is actually wonderful
for something as complicated
as a legal document.
Now, legal documents
are pretty interesting.
They have very stringent
requirements for formatting,
structure, wording,
and they often
involve intense
collaboration, your team
or your company's legal team.
Docs can save you a lot of time
with this existing workflow.
So here is a workflow that
you probably go through.
You start with drafting
a legal document where
you might start from an
existing template of some sort.
After that you're
collaborating with your team,
working with your legal
team to get it to a state
where you can actually share
it outside your company.
We're going to walk
through a scenario.
We are all going to be this
company on the right known
as Chip, and we are working
on a new partnership
with a company known as RGB.
And we're going to
seal this partnership
with this document, the
supplier relations agreement.
Now there is a particular format
that we need to start with.
In the past, you probably
used Word templates that
were emailed back and forth.
You maybe had to figure out who
to ping, find the right team
site, and then that team
site was probably down.
And so you'd go, and
you'd cry a little bit.
You'd come back, You'd
repeat the process.
It's a little painful.
Last year in Google Docs, we
launched custom templates.
This means that templates
that are relevant to you
are now centralized
in one place.
And it's actually not a
lot for your-- not a lot
of work for your admin.
Once the admin sets this up,
a trusted user in your company
can upload a new legal template.
And within just a
couple of moments,
it's available to everyone in
your company to find and use.
In this example here, you'll
see that the user is selecting
a document to convert to a
template, selecting a category,
and boom it's ready to use.
So we have a great
starting point,
but we now need to add
a lot of custom edits.
There are two types
of edits, formatting
or the actual content.
Let's start with formatting.
Now I heard this
rumor going around,
and the rumor said Docs does not
have any formatting features.
And we here like to
debunk fake news.
So what I'm going
to walk through
is just a small subset
of the formatting
features in Google Docs.
And this is actually real time.
This is how fast
I work every day.
And what-- the point
that I want to make
is that over the
past few years we've
been adding a lot of longtail
features to Google Docs.
And the product is a
cloud native product.
So it changes every
time you use it.
And so you may not
know what we actually
have in the product today.
So after the session,
go try out Google Docs.
Try doing what I'm
doing here, and you'll
see that we have pretty much
everything that you need.
If you don't, come talk to me.
We'll get it in the product.
In fact, we wanted to
challenge ourselves.
We took a US Supreme Court
opinion, because we thought
it had pretty complicated
formatting, and we said,
let's try to recreate
this in Google Docs.
And, actually, Alan
took this one, and he
was able to do this in--
was it 15 minutes?
15 minutes without any errors,
which is pretty amazing.
But let's get back
to our example
with Chip manufacturing.
So we have a draft of our
document, we've formatted it,
and now we need to get
feedback from others
in our organization.
So here you see that
we've invited a few people
from our organization.
They're collaborating real time.
There editing several parts of
the document at the same time.
They're adding comments.
They're adding
comments to comments
and creating [INAUDIBLE]
compositions.
No one had to save a file and
email the draft to someone else
and say, hey, this is v1,
now it's v2, now it's vfinal,
now it's vfinal for real,
vfinal not really, let's
do that again.
Instead, it's all happening
in the same document
at the same time.
Here's something
you may not know.
The Docs apps on desktop,
iOS, and Android,
actually work offline.
And when you make edits offline,
and you come back online,
we will actually do a merge
of the edits you did offline
with the edits that were done
by the other collaborators.
It's pretty-- it's pretty cool.
You might be seeing
something interesting here,
which is we're
actually assigning
action items to specific
people on your team.
It turns out that people
spend a lot of time
at work tracking down
colleagues to get work done--
to just ask them to
follow up on small tasks.
In fact, research has
shown that people spend up
to 20% of their work
week just doing this.
That's about an entire day.
So we've added intelligence
to Google Docs.
You'll notice here that as
I type Ryan Weber to review
overall proposal, or Allen
Yang to check in with legal,
Docs intelligently suggests
action items on the side.
We've detected the
sentence, we've
parsed it to understand
what the AI is
and who it needs to be assigned
to, and with just one click,
you can assign the action item.
The impact of this
when you bring it
to all products across
G Suite, and you
think about this impact
multiplying with a large team,
it really adds up.
And the overall goal here is
really just taking back time
that you might spend on
mundane repetitive tasks,
and instead giving you
back this time and energy,
so that you can do the real
creative and strategic work.
So we now have a document
that's in a pretty final state,
and were going to start sharing
this with the external partner.
Alan is going to walk
you through the flow what
happens next.
ALLEN YANG: Cool.
Thanks, Vishnu.
So our team is done with
our pass at the document,
and we are ready to engage our
counterparts at RGB Suppliers.
So at this point,
we'd love to see
a quick show of hands, who's
a little wary of sharing
documents externally?
OK.
OK, right.
Data privacy is certainly
something to be careful of,
but we are very happy to
say that with Google Docs
and with G Suite and
more broadly, you always
have full control over who
has access to a document,
and what they can do
with that document.
So let's take a look at
some of these features.
As you're probably aware,
with Google Docs, when you're
working internally, you can
share a document with somebody
by giving them only view-only
or comment-only rights.
And it turns out that you can
do this when sharing externally
as well.
So if you aren't seeking
somebody's comments or edits
to a particular
document, you can just
give them view-only rights.
Let's say, for example,
that you did give somebody
external edit rights
to a document, well,
it turns out later
you can always
come back to the document and
look at its revision history
to see exactly who changed what.
There are also
some advance things
you can do when sharing
a document with anybody
internal or external, and
these kinds of settings
include things like
preventing them
from adding further
people to the document,
preventing them from
downloading the document,
or even preventing them from
copying from the document.
Another useful
feature for sharing
is what we call
expiring permissions.
So this is found in the Advanced
Settings of the Share dialog,
as you can see from
the quick video here.
And what this
allows you to do is
to give somebody permission
to a document for only
a certain amount of time.
So if you don't want to give
them permission forever,
this is the easy way to do it
And the final sharing
feature we wanted to bring up
is Drive's data loss
prevention feature called DLP.
So with this, a domain
admin can actually
set predefined content
detectors over the entire corpus
of your company's documents.
When one of these
detectors detects
what it was set
up to find, it'll
actually enforce certain
sharing rules on that document.
So for example, you might set
a rule that says if a document
has the word confidential in it
or if a document has what looks
like a credit card number in it,
you can actually say that those
documents cannot be
shared externally, period.
So this is a handy tool
for admins to up the data
security a little bit.
So with all of these
sharing features,
we always strive to
give you full control
over exactly who has
access to your documents,
and what they can do with it.
So we have successfully shared
our document externally, no?
And our collaborators at RGB
are taking a pass over it.
It seems like the video's
not quite working.
But let's imagine that
our collaborators at RGB
are taking a pass
over this document.
So in the past, what
would have happened
is that they would've
added comments,
they would've made some
revisions to the document,
and then they would have sent
over a new version to you.
Sort of, like a giant v2
with a lot of things for you
to process.
But it turns out that
with Google Docs,
all the same kinds of
collaboration features used
internally are available
for use externally as well.
So imagine, for
example, that some
of our partners
from RGB suppliers
are working through
this document.
They are going through, they're
leaving comments, which Vishnu
pointed out earlier,
but they can also
make suggested changes, which
should remind you of, sort of,
the red lining capabilities
that you might be familiar with.
With all of these
suggested changes,
any changes from
one given author
will show up to you
in a particular color,
and the exact change
that they're proposing
will show up to you
on the right-hand side
near any comments.
For each individual
suggestion, you
can choose to accept or
reject it in real time,
or you can come back
later to the document
and do a full pass
over all suggestions.
Coming soon is a
new feature, which
will allow you to
accept or reject
all the changes on
a document at once,
and you'll also have
the ability to preview
the document as if all
changes were either
accepted or rejected.
So these are improvements
on the traditional redlining
experience that we think will
help you become even more
efficient when dealing
with documents like this.
We have some happy
lawyers in the audience.
Great.
So, so far we have
been talking just
about collaborating
between G Suite
users, which was a
great experience that we
care very much about.
But we know realistically
that a lot of times
your legal teams might be
collaborating with people
who are still using
Word, and we are
very happy to tell
you here today
that that's completely fine.
We don't need to
hold it against them.
So on the left here, you see
a document by our friends
over at RGB Suppliers.
They're still using
Word, and you'll
notice that this document looks
like a legal contract, right.
It has some particular
formatting about it.
It looks like it came
from an RGB template,
because it has a blue
header across the top,
and there are even
a couple of comments
in here already for us.
So our counterparts
at RGB save this file
and email it over to us, and we
open this file in Google Docs.
And we get what we
see on the right here.
So you notice a few things.
First is that the formatting
and content are preserved.
You even get the little
blue bar across the top.
And you'll notice that the
comments originally in word
show up as native
Google Docs comments,
so you can do the threaded
conversations and the assigned
action items that Vishnu
was talking about earlier.
And why do we invest in this?
We invest in this, because we
know that a lot of our users
are still interacting with
people who are on Office,
and so we want to make
file conversion fidelity
something that's a very high
quality feature within Google
Docs.
Great.
So we've settled on the
contents and the formatting
of a document.
And now we want
to get signatures
from both parties on this
particular legal contract.
It turns out that
the G Suite ecosystem
has a lot of partners
who are building out
high-quality integrations
between parts of G
Suite and their own products.
And this is great
for us, because
for our electronic
signature needs,
for example, we might
choose to use Docusign.
Docusign is a
solution that works.
It has over 100 million
users in 188 countries.
And moreover, it's a
recommended for G Suite partner.
So all recommended partners have
to go through certain security
and integration
standards reviews.
And this is because we know that
when dealing with a third party
ecosystem, data security
becomes even more important.
So Docusign has a
number of integrations
with different parts
of the suite already,
but we are excited to
announce that they're
building even more.
So towards the end
of last year, they
released their new
Android add-ons,
so you can sign from
your Android device.
And here on Next, we are
very excited to preannounce
their new Docs add-on, which
is what you see in the sidebar
here.
With this new Docs
add-on, users will
be able to finish editing
a file in Google Docs,
and then they will be able to
begin the Docusign signature
experience via this add-on.
This is what we mean
by making workflows
more efficient for our users.
Moreover, this new
Docs add-on will
be making an appearance
in another new feature
that we're preannouncing
here on Next
called Template Integrations.
Template Integration is a
pairing of a specific template
with a specific add-on.
So why might this be useful
for legal use cases, you say?
So let's say, for
example, your company has
a number of standardized
legal contracts
that you want all your
employees to have access to.
Moreover, let's assume
that your company
uses Docusign for its
electronic signature needs.
If you were to take
those legal contracts
and upload them to
your template gallery
that Vishnu described earlier,
and if you paired them
with the Docusign add-on, all of
a sudden all of your employees
who are creating documents
from those templates
will know exactly the right
electronic signature tool
to use, and they will have
it at their fingertips
when they're ready.
So we're very excited about
this partnership with Docusign
and with other partners that
could help with your legal use
cases.
We also wanted to point out
that it is possible for you
to create your own extensions
to G Suite via App Script.
If you want some ideas
on different tools
to build out using
App Script, feel
free to visit our public web
page, known as the G Suite
Transformation Gallery.
But for example,
you might consider
building a Docs add-on
that lets you paste
standardized clauses of
legal contracts into Docs,
or you could build a tool
with Apps Script that
helps you keep track of
exactly who has signed an NDA.
A third integration that
we wanted to bring up
is what we're calling
Docs Storage Integrations.
Some of you may have heard
the announcement last year,
but with these new Docs
Storage Integrations,
we're allowing users to use
the Google Docs editors--
so Google Docs,
Sheets, and Slides--
with the third party
storage solution of choice.
And so I'm curious
at this point, who
here uses a third party
storage solution that's
not Google Drive?
Cool, so great some
people in the audience.
So this feature, hopefully,
will be very useful for you.
So today, to help us see
what the value of this
could be for your
legal teams, we're
very excited to have
Raja Balakrishnana
from the first content--
first storage integration
partner we announced, Box.
RAJA BALAKRISHANA:
Thank you, Allen.
Hello, Everyone.
I'm Raja Balakrishnan.
I'm a product manager
at Box, and I'm
working with our
counterparts at Google
to tightly integrate Box
and Google Docs, Sheets,
and Slides.
So I'm very excited to
be here in front of you
to share with you on what we're
doing about the integration,
and also to give you
some insights on how
Box and Google together can
help you address your legal use
cases.
So before I jump
into that, I want
to share with you what
Box does well, right,
and how this integration
will benefit you.
So at a very high level, Box
lets you store your content,
secure your content,
share it, and govern it
all in one place, right.
So that is what
primarily Box does.
But you spent the last 10
years building services
that enable you, services
like compliance services,
reliability, security,
and so on and so forth,
so you could manage all
your content in one place,
but at scale, right.
You can manage all
that content at scale.
So what we're really working
on with the Google team here
is to, kind of,
make sure that you
get all the benefits of the
Google collaboration suites
coauthoring, editing,
and a lot of stuff
that we talked about
here in this conference,
but at the same time
maintain a centralized source
of your truth so
all those changes
can be saved back directly
to Box in real time, right.
So what this means is you could
be within Box, if you're a Box
user, but you can still create
documents, slides, and sheets.
You can open them.
You could collaborate and
share all that content
without ever having
to leave Box, right.
Your content still
lives in Box, but you
get all the collaboration
benefits of Google Docs,
Sheets, and Slides.
So that's what we're
working on this year.
Before I jump into
some of the ideas
that Box and Google can help you
specifically with on legal use
cases, we strongly believe
that the technologies that
are available to busy
legal professionals today
are challenging, right.
They're challenging to use.
That are a few examples here.
I'll just highlight
three of those.
It's just not easy for
busy professionals,
legal professionals to access
content on the go, right.
This could be mobile access.
This could be remote access.
It's just not
easy-to-access content.
Second, security sharing
and receiving content
is just not easy.
It's tedious, in fact.
And I'll give you one example.
Some of the lawyers in the
room might associate with this.
I've observed that some
legal professionals still
put their case material
on CDs and ship it out
to their clients, right.
So that kind of
stuff still happens.
And technologies like FTP,
Extranet, all these legacy
technologies, they are
definitely not easy to use,
they're not necessarily
secure, and in many cases,
they're not compliant, right.
So these are some of the
challenges that we think you
or the teams that
you serve face.
So let me give
you a few examples
of how Box and Google together
can help you address these.
In the interest of time, I'll
just pick one use case, right.
I'm going to pick
litigation case management,
but just like any other
collaboration use case,
you could imagine that this
would require collaboration
with multiple parties.
And these parties could be
collaborators within the team,
these could be your attorneys,
these could be your paralegal
folks, and so on and so forth.
This could also be your
clients, and in some cases
occasionally, this could
be your opposing counsel
with whom you'd have to
collaborate on content, right.
So this is the use case.
And let me quickly tell you
how Box and Google can help
you address these use cases.
First of all, Box provides a
very highly organized folder
structure.
So what that means, why
is that relevant to you?
Your legal teams can
bring all their content
into one centralized
location, right.
This could be all case material
relevant to a single client,
or it could be case
material across the cases
that your teams handled, right.
In many cases, we
have noticed that this
can help you
completely replace FTP
servers and other technologies
that are used for this purpose.
The second area that
we can jointly help you
is we offer a great permissions
model on documents and folders.
In fact, we offer seven
levels of permissions starting
from preview only rights
all the way up to editing
rights on documents.
So what this really means is
as a legal team, when you're
working, when you're
thinking about collaboration,
you could define who
has a view-only access
to the document or the case
matter that you're working on,
but not edit, right.
So this is very important
in a collaboration use case.
And third-- and remember we
talked about the shipping CD
use case-- we can
really help there,
because Box and Google together
can help you share content--
securely shared content--
not just with a few people,
not just with
people in the room,
but people across geographically
distributed in all locations.
This could be clients
in many cases.
And the reason
this is relevant is
you guys deal with complicated
remote access technologies.
They're just hard
to set up, right.
We heard about VPN
setting up VPNs
in the Keynote presentation.
It's just really
hard to do that,
and you don't have
to do that, right.
Box and Google together can help
you address those use cases.
You could share, you
could collaborate content
very easily.
But with all these capabilities,
these native content management
capabilities of Box and the
collaboration capabilities
that we're offering with
Google, what do you do
is you could change the
behavior of the teams
that you're working with.
I'll give you one example.
Sending out attachments in
emails is not the way to do it,
right.
Specifically in
your use case, you'd
have to deal with multiple
versions of the same document,
right.
Staying on top of it with
sharing it over email
is just not easy.
With Box and Google
together, that's
going to be extremely
easy for you, especially
your legal teams, to stay
on top of the case matter
even though there
are multiple versions
that you'll have to deal with.
And finally, in addition to
all the native management
capabilities that I described
and the integration that we're
doing with Google, we
also offer integrations
with documents signing
services like Docusign.
Just like Google
integration, we at Box
also have an integration.
So that means that you
have a lot of choice
to choose the right integration
for your specific use case.
And for your specific
legal use cases, attorneys
and paralegals and clients,
it's easier and faster for them
to sign those documents.
So in closing and
summary, I just
want to leave you
with the thought
that we at Box are
working very closely
and tightly with our partners
at Google, so that you could
leverage the collaboration
capabilities of Google,
the content management
capabilities of Box,
and you can address the
tough legal use cases
and do all the strategic
work that you need to do.
If you have any questions,
I'll stick around here.
You could also drop us an
email at sales@box.com,
if you want expert further.
Thank you.
ALLEN YANG: Thanks
very much, Raja.
Great, so where are we now?
We've spoken a little bit
about the features of Docs,
about formatting
legal documents,
about sharing, and
about the ecosystem.
But there are still some very,
very important topics keeping
us from happy hour,
and they are things
like security and compliance.
And we know these are
very big deals, especially
in the legal context.
So in order to do a
bit of a deep dive
into some of these
topics, we are
very excited to have a few
of our colleagues here today.
First off, we have
Mike Chasan, who
is product counsel
at G Suite, who
will talk a little
bit about what it's
like working with Google
Docs and with Chromebooks
as a lawyer at Google.
Thanks, Mike.
OK.
MIKE CHASAN: Hi, everybody.
My name is Mike Chasan,
and I am product counsel
for Google Docs.
So I get to spend a lot
of time with these guys.
Yeah, so when I started working
at Google six-plus years ago,
I went through my first
day of Noogler orientation.
I learned all about the
Google tools and applications,
and it was all great.
I learned all about Google Docs.
They had these
interactive demos.
It was very exciting.
And then on my second day, I
walked into the legal offices,
and they said, yeah, Google
Docs is great for internal use,
but you're a lawyer.
You need to put Word
on your computer.
Do it now.
It's the first thing.
So that's what things were
like at the very beginning.
About four years ago, I switched
to using Docs completely
for my practice and
gave up Word entirely.
I might say that
I did it because I
like these guys and the team
and I want to support them.
The honest truth is the new
Pixel Chromebook came out,
and I really wanted one, and
the only way I could get one
was if I committed to give up
my MacBook and my copy of Word.
So I got the new fancy computer.
It does the Konami
code nights blinking,
and I really like that.
And so I just worked
around my issues with Docs
and learned to love it.
So I just wanted to give
you a few practice tips
that I've developed
over the years
to help you make that transition
from using a mixed-mode Word
and Docs environment to
working completely in Docs.
So the first point is
collaboration is king.
The most compelling
use of Google Docs
is to collaborate,
to get feedback,
to leave action items
for your teammates,
to drop in questions and notes.
So even if you are working
in a Word document,
and even if you are going to
keep it in a Word document,
the first thing I
do when I get a Word
document is import it into
Docs and share it with my team.
That way I can consolidate
all that feedback,
see what's going
on, and then proceed
how I'm going to proceed
with the document.
Workflows are also
really easy in Docs.
In advance of Next,
I had a lot of emails
to review and approve,
a lot of blog posts
to review and approve.
It's really easy in Docs to
drop a table, a list of everyone
that needs to approve a
document at the top of the file,
and then everyone can
look at the same document
at the same time.
They can drop their names into
it when they've approved it
and sign off.
You don't have to worry about
which version you've looked at.
And you can even look
at revision history
to see if the
document has changed
since you were last in it.
The other thing
to remember is not
everything is collaborative.
Engineers love to collaborate.
Lawyers don't like to
collaborate as well,
or aren't as good at it.
When working with
an external party,
sometimes I find
it helpful to make
internal copies and external
copies of the same document.
That way my internal team can
discuss the document freely,
put in comments, edits,
in the internal version.
I can review that, consolidate,
come with the final position,
and bring that into
an external copy
that I share with our partner.
And then when I get comments
back from the partner,
I could do the same
thing in reverse,
bring their comments back
for internal discussion.
The permission model that
Vishnu and Allen talked about
is very helpful to
make sure that partners
that only have view can't
see revision history.
But sometimes when you
give them edit access,
it's important to remember
that all editors can
see revision history.
So if you make a new
copy of a document,
it's a way of resetting
revision history
and making sure that
the new document doesn't
contain any of the past
comments and suggestions.
And lastly, exporting to other
file formats is very easy.
So if you do need to send an
attachment to somebody that
cannot work or will not work
in Google Docs, it's very easy.
It's one click away to
email out a Word version
or a PDF version
of the document.
So I hope those were
some helpful tips that
can help you guys
transition into using Docs
more in your legal practices.
ALLEN YANG: Well,
thanks very much, Mike.
So up next we'd like to
welcome Mark Crandall, who's
head of Google Compliance
for Google Cloud, who
will be talking about some
of the topics that might be
on your mind as you
consider adopting
a cloud-based
productivity solution.
Mark.
MARC CRANDALL: Hi, folks.
Thanks for listening.
So just because we talk
about collaboration
in the cloud with regards to
legal professionals, lawyers,
contract administrators
doesn't necessarily
mean that you can or should put
confidential data in the cloud.
If you're a lawyer representing
a company that works--
that works with information
in a regulated market
then, of course, you need
it to conduct an assessment
of that in the first place.
There's a detailed
session on this tomorrow,
but I did want to cover
some very high level points.
Because we actually
do have millions
of customers that are
using our services,
and they are doing it dealing
with regulated information.
So the first thing that
I want to talk about
is conducting a
compliance assessment.
Now, I've been at Google for
a little more than 10 years,
particularly with G Suite
from the very beginning,
and we do not have the legal
experience or the compliance
experience of all of our
customers around the world.
We have 190 so odd
countries, and let's say
we've gotten five
verticals in each country--
financial services,
personal data, health care,
manufacturing, investing.
That's, what, tens of
thousands, hundreds, millions
of different combinations.
So our customers are the
experts in their own compliance
obligations and their own
compliance requirements.
However, we have been
doing this very long,
and we've worked with a lot
of regulatory authorities
in helping to create
a product that
can be adopted by as many
customers as possible worldwide
in light of their regulatory
compliance obligations.
So I would submit that when
you're reviewing Google--
and I am bringing
these questions up,
because we've addressed these
many, many times over the years
and have good answers--
you want to consider,
for example,
what are the security
capabilities of Google
with respect to what
you're doing on-site?
You've probably seen some
of our security sessions.
We've got hundreds of
security engineers,
but I'd submit
that in most cases
our security capabilities
will far exceed
that of most of our customers.
You have to think about
who owns the data that you
put into the cloud.
With G Suite and with Google,
your data remains yours.
You place it into our systems.
That does not change anything.
We also provide restrictions
on how data is used.
We provide a data
processing amendment,
which obligates us not
to use the data for ads.
No ads are seen.
No data is used for ads.
We don't use the data
for any other purpose
than to provide the services.
That's particularly important
in the areas of, for example,
European personal
data protection.
Or when it comes to
the United States,
when it comes to FERPA, which
is the protection of student
records or directory
information.
So HIPAA, with regards to
placing PHI into our system,
so data use restrictions.
We provide obligation-- we
obligate ourselves to provide
you data incident notification,
which is very important in lots
of regulated markets and also
for the general data protection
regulation, which is going to be
coming up in Europe next year,
the GDPR.
We provide an affirmation
that once you delete data,
it will be purged
from our system.
It will be gone, right.
It doesn't just stick around.
I don't know how many people
on using on-prem software
wipe their hard
drives every time
they delete a file or document.
Data portability.
We provide assurances that you
can take your data and go home,
if you want to leave G Suite.
You also want to consider
what type of data
you're storing in
the system, right.
As I mentioned, we have
millions of customers
that store all types of data
that you want to make that
as part of your assessment.
And then the last thing
I want to talk about
with regards to the
compliance assessment
is how do you know that I'm not
lying to you about everything
I say we do?
How do you know?
I could just be telling you
anything you want to hear.
The way you know this
is because we undergo
third-party audits of our
security and data protection
capabilities.
We invite third-party auditors
to come in and examine
our processes against more than
100 controls to help ensure
that what we do--
what we say we do
actually what we do.
So with respect to that,
we provide our customers
with a SOC audit report.
You see I mentioned
SOC 2 and SOC 3 where
auditors, particularly
with a SOC 2 report,
create a very detailed,
highly confidential assessment
of our data protection
capabilities, which
can be reviewed by your
chief security officer,
chief risk officer, chief
information officer,
to be able to determine whether
our security capabilities align
with your own requirements.
And I would submit that
I think that they might.
But the nice thing about-- the
interesting thing about SOC 2
is while it's a very
detailed assessment,
and it's 200 or 300 pages long,
to distinguish that from ISO
certification--
you'll see here nice--
three nice little ISO
badges, ISO 27001,
which is a security
standard, ISO 27017, which
is a brand new Cloud security
standard specific to Cloud,
and then ISO 27018, which is
a new standard with relation
to data protection,
specifically privacy.
So we provide SOC 2
type audits, but we also
have achieved ISO
certification with respect
to these three standards--
27001, 17, and 18.
It means we've attained a
certain level of compliance
that was dictated not by
us, not by the industry,
but by the International
Organization
for Standardization,
a global body that
designs these certifications.
The reason why we
use a global body
is because it helps ensure
that as many customers as
possible in as many
markets as possible
can leverage these third-party
audits and certifications.
And finally, we have
industry-specific and
region-specific regulatory
frameworks as well.
You heard me mention
HIPAA with regards
to the United States health
care information, PHI.
We can accept HIPAA
information into G Suite
into some of our services.
We are also Fed ramp
certified, which
is very difficult
to obtain, which
allows US government agencies
to store data, Fed ramp
moderate data into our system.
And then finally, for our
many, many customers in Europe
or those that have
or multinationals
that have end
users in Europe, we
offer data export mechanisms,
things like EU model contract
clauses, which we've offered
for customers for years.
Incidentally, who here
heard about the invalidation
of Safe Harbor?
OK, that had to do
with whether Europeans
were allowed to export
personal data from Europe
to the rest of the world.
Safe Harbor was invalidated,
but model clauses
was an alternative to
that which we offered
for years before this happened.
Why?
Because we know that model
clauses are important.
Data export is critical to
our customers in Europe,
and so we've been
offering it since then.
And we also implement
Privacy Shield--
participate in Privacy
Shield as another way
to allow data to be
exported from Europe.
There are other
frameworks in the UK
that we can talk about as well
or other parts of the world,
but just the synopsis.
And the last thing
I want to mention
is I talked about all
the great things we do.
I talked about the third-party
audits and certifications
that you can review to make sure
that we're not lying to you,
but then we also need to
put it in writing, right.
So our data processing
amendment is
where you can find the
meat of a lot of the stuff.
We obligate
ourselves to restrict
how we process your data.
This is where we promise
that we'll actually
do these third-party
audits and certifications.
We have to promise it in
writing, otherwise, again,
it won't mean anything.
We promised to delete your
data when you want us to.
We promised to provide
you notification--
I hope it doesn't happen,
but of data incidents.
Because this is required for
many regulatory frameworks.
If-- I hope it never
happens-- but if there
is a data incident with
your cloud provider,
you need to know about it.
Because you may need to
fulfill your own regulatory
obligations.
So we provide that commitment.
We tell you about
any vendors we might
use for sub-- for processing.
We don't use very many
third-party vendors,
because we are Google, but for
technical support or customer
support we may.
And we also disclose
all of our subsidiaries
that are involved with
processing data, right.
Because we have Google's
all over the world.
We outline our security
measures as well.
So this is the combination
of compliance assessment
where you can partner
with us, your compliance
assessment with our
expertise in the cloud,
utilizing our
third-party auditing
tools to verify
what we do, and then
finally the contractual
obligations that we provide
to you to put in writing what
we say we're going to do.
Thank you very much.
ALLEN YANG: Thanks
very much, Mark.
And our final guest is Ivan
Passos, product manager
at Google Vault, which is a
very useful tool for dealing
with litigation holds.
So, Ivan.
IVAN PASSOS: Thanks, Allen.
So basically what
Google Vault does is it
provides you the ability
to implement e-discovery
and compliance into G Suite.
So if you're looking at
implementing legal documents
and using documents for
your legal processes,
they will be covered
by Google Vault,
and they will have full
compliance checks and also
the ability to generate those
documents in a legal case
or for any internal
investigations.
What Google Vault does is
basically through retention
policies, you're able to define
exactly when your data should
be kept and for how long and
when your data should be gone,
and this is done automatically.
Your IT managers will
be able to just set up
those retention policies.
They are done for each
specific data type.
You can do that for G-mail,
for Docs, for Groups,
for the different
applications in the G Suite,
and you can set multiple
types of policies
of requirements and criteria.
You can say that it should
be kept indefinitely
for the legal team or for
three years for a job in et
cetera, et cetera.
So we have a lot of
granularity there.
And once you've set up
your proper policies
for retention in data
lifecycle management,
you can then search
for data as needed.
You can search
for documents that
are relevant for a specific
investigation or case.
And once you code that
data and narrow it
down to the specific data
set you're looking for,
you can then export that
data either to provide
to external counsel
or to move it
on to another investigation
aid discovery tool
or to use it internally.
Google Vault is part
of just G Suite.
It's actually included in G
Suite business and G Suite
enterprise.
And this complements
what Allen and Vishnu
were talking about
when you have document
functionality for
your legal teams
for producing contracts
and et cetera.
Google Vault provides
you full coverage
for e-discovery and compliance
for G Suite as a whole.
That's it.
Thank you.
ALLEN YANG: Thank you very much.
Thanks very much to all
of our guest speakers.
So let's recap a little bit
about what we've seen today.
At the beginning,
we first talked
about a lot of the
features that Google Docs
has to help you create very
well-formatted and powerful
legal documents.
We then talked a
little bit about what
it's like to collaborate
on Google Docs,
including touching
upon some features
that you might
already be used to.
Things like commenting
or suggestive changes,
which is an improvement
upon red lining.
Here we also talked about
various sharing controls
you have, and we talked about
file conversion fidelity, which
is something we pay a
lot of attention to.
And we also touched upon
the G Suite ecosystem,
which offers a lot
of partner tools
which could help you
accomplish your legal needs.
And then finally we talked
about the very important issues
of adoption, of security,
and of compliance,
and we had our three guest
speakers who brought some more
color onto these topics in
the very black and white world
of legal documents.
So we wanted to
conclude by showing you
this video about what
Iceland did with Google Docs.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- So, I'm Thorvaldur Gulfason,
Professor of Economics
at the University of Iceland.
I was one of the 25 members
of the constitutional assembly
that adapted the post-crash
constitution for Iceland.
And we were delighted to
use Google Docs in order
to make our work easier.
On many, many occasions
we saved time and energy
by doing the drafting together,
not necessarily sitting
in the same room.
We could be in different
places using Google Docs.
I'm convinced that our
constitution is a better
document than it would've been
without these technological
advantages.
[END PLAYBACK]
So yes, a country has actually
written their constitution
with Google Docs.
So in conclusion,
we just want to say
that we hope you'll go
back to your companies
and ask your legal teams and
all your super users of word
to give Google Docs a
shot, because we think
they'll be very surprised
by just how much they're
capable of.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]